today
uh the ken and i'm going to go through
the basics
the same as i've done with the joe
when carrying the and carrying the can
hold it down quite this much
also about 30 centimetres okay and just
keep going inside don't
don't have it don't have it hanging out
like that just make
sure that uh it's comfortable you know
it's a balanced way
just uh keep it comfortable the heavier
the ken the better there's a lot of them
light cheap ones out there if that's all
you've got um
that's what you've got but a heavier
wooden can is better because you can
feel it more
when you're cutting
when you when you bow
don't stick your butt out like that
keep keep your body there and you tip
your head
okay
on the gas mask
okay so keep your butt uh tucked in
when you when you take
again and you're gonna bring it out
but the footwork you can
find this in books over but the footwork
is smaller if you just look down at the
footwork
it's smaller and
in training there's a training that we
can do
with with smaller feet footsteps okay
so so four smaller footsteps
okay so from here i
bowed to my partner i go over to
my my can the
contrast my hand is
open the small the little finger closes
first
and then the next one then the next one
then the next one
okay you don't just grab it and close
all your all your hands
little finger next one next one next one
okay
so
can not suck out ken tucked in
you don't the person in front of me
doesn't want to see the tip
okay so perhaps you can see the tip
let me just pull this
line down
[Music]
can you see the tip if you can see
that past my hand that ken then it's
wrong
it needs to be hidden okay
it's something from the from the past
okay so you bow
not with your you take
your hands open small finger closes
first
and the next one the next one it comes
it doesn't go out it comes up the side
of your body like a fan
it comes with your body like a fan and
you put your front foot out can you put
it away
same thing
it's like a fan
so a few a few uh folds here
so i bowed
i'll come here i open my foot
i open my foot timing timing is
everything
and a fan the fan
wants to be as if
as if it's your hand
icchio
your hand is naturally down here isn't
it it's
not natural so that's where it is so it
comes up with a great
go to a show they used to say sensei
used to say
think that you are a massive ocean the
wave is
the ocean is coming forward
okay so here when it comes out
like a fan
so when you end up in the this position
command
you're dynamic you haven't had to now
pump yourself up and get in this
position you were in there from the
beginning
so you've done your bowel you've kept
your sword in
and when this comes out
when it goes back a lot of people do
this be careful of this
because this is a weakness be careful
this
don't let it sort of like come back into
it's it's always important so it comes
out like a fan
dynamic and it goes
back like a fan dynamic
etica is so important
ready
no okay so really
very ready position come on
it can feel a little stiff you can feel
that
you know you can get tense through
trying too hard
so right nice
dynamic energy like a fan coming out
when coming back no but like a fan
i hope you know what i mean by fans if
you get this in your hand
hey all right
right
it comes out of you look
hey out of you like your spirit
hey your spirit
spirit is coming out
like a fan i'm gonna just show you this
end now
and as with the joe my little finger on
this
hand is half on and half off
it's the first two fingers the first two
fingers
that grip the ken and the rest
just wrap around it
when you finish your ken cut
you squeeze the right
hand fingers and the left hand fingers
as if you have a towel and you're
ringing water out of it
you know you've just been in the sea
and you ring you know so this
twisting and ringing motion
it's it's a it's a quick it's a
quick quick quick quick motion
and release quick release quick release
quick
release
okay
so
try each suburi as a separate suburi
it's important that you
when they when you finish squeeze
try to have the mind clear you know what
to do you you know if you're not
if you're doing this you know what cebu
you're doing
breathe in exhale
squeeze release release all the body
release my body
all right for beginners new people
you want the small you want the tip
to touch more of your back
you touch more of your back with this
so that you learn how to get a big
arc length attach your back so you get a
bigger arc
that's higher grades um you don't do
that you comes about here
and the higher you get the less the arc
i think
hey hey
okay so so there's
in aikido there's contradictions but if
they're good contradictions
then they're okay it's just that who
knows when it's a good contradiction or
bad one
like you know it's very simple it's us
that complicate it
if you swing this your wrists will get
pumped up they'll get bigger
your arms will get bigger you know so
you need flexibility as well
and i run lazy yoga
films as well and i recommend that you
you find ways of keeping your body
subtle if
you do circuit training
then to me it's the complete wrong
uh training if you're
doing it to build muscle if you're doing
this to telling your body
you need to make sure it's very flexible
and loose as well
okay be good like you know you need to
be very loose very flexible
most people don't realize if you can't
touch them you know if you can't touch
your toes
with your arms straight out you need to
stretch this back you need to do some
work
okay i've said enough
the outside i'll show you the
second subway and the thirds are buried
but if i just come forward and then
come here on the third berry just notice
where my can
is you can should be able to see
the can i put it against the
ken you can see past my hands
do you remember me saying earlier when i
bowed
you know when i had it on the other side
and i bowed out i said you
you mustn't see the end this is the same
on the
third birthday
okay the enemy or the
you know that my partner mustn't see the
tip
it must be hidden i'll show it from this
side
okay it mustn't be out here
it mustn't be out there it has to be
so really it's in the line it's in line
with my
with my arm as i come closer
you see with my arm with my hand around
it
but this is no good okay
so i'll come forward
it they can't see it
so when i come back i keep it close
i don't bring it out i keep it close to
my body
and then cut well when we have more
space i'll go into more detail about
that
maybe if you have a mirror or you have
enough room
or outside and you have a glass door or
something
you need to check where the can is
okay let's please uh
try those things and and we'll develop
it there's so many teachers out there
teaching you suburbies
carter's human touches and that's great
i want to teach the important detail
that normally people don't want
to train because they might find it
boring but to be a real
100 martial artists you need the finer
details
work on the finer details since he said
to me speed will come it will come
naturally
i don't want to go